[Musique]
c'était un nom si doux à l'oreille
si séduisants synonyme de richesse de
style de pouvoir mais c'était aussi une
malédiction
j'ai été un gucci toute ma vie
ton nom il est dans les livres
d'histoire par l'eau tu es un goudji
alors habille-toi en conséquence c'est
chimique
[Musique]
gucci a besoin de sang neuf
c'est le moment de faire du ménage
c'est ma famille
j'en fais partie
c'est de la dynamite cette fille quand
elle choisit elle a le diable au corps
[Musique]
je me considère pas spécialement comme
quelqu'un de très moral mais je suis
juste
[Musique]
sais-tu garder un secret
au nom du père du fils et de la maison
gucci